Wer ist denn da?
* Titelmelodie *
Untertitel: ARD Text
im Auftrag von Funk (2017)
Freunde der Sonne, heute habe ich
einen besonderen Gast bei mir.
Das ist Lisa.
Lisa ist Deutsch-Expertin.
Wir kennen uns eigentlich schon.
Wir machen nämlich zusammen
das Nachhilfeformat "Musste wissen".
Da macht Mai Chemie
und ich mach Deutsch.
Heute schauen wir uns an,
was Sprache mit unserem Gehirn macht.
Und aus aktuellem Anlass auch,
mit welchen sprachlichen Tricks
uns Politiker beeinflussen.
Okay, gerade als Naturwissenschaftler
denkt man sich gerne:
Sprache, bla bla, bla blubb.
Fachbegriffe sind ja schön und gut.
Aber jeder weiß: echte Wissenschaft
macht man nur mit Zahlen.
Das ist natürlich Quatsch.
Bzw. es ist naiv zu glauben,
dass man den Großteil der Menschen
mit trockenen Zahlen überzeugen kann.
Ich kann da nur auf unser Video
zu den Fake-News verweisen.
Was Menschen vielmehr beeinflusst,
wenn auch viel subtiler, ist Sprache.
Das fängt schon an,
wenn wir Babys sind.
Also dann, wenn wir noch gar keine
Sprache verstehen außer Babysprache.
Ah, wer ist denn da?
Ja wer ist denn da?
Kennt ihr doch, oder?
Unerträglich hohe Stimme,
melodischer Singsang, absurde Gestik.
(sehr hoch) Ja wer ist denn da?
Diese Baby- oder Ammensprache
ist überall auf der Welt gleich.
Es geht eigentlich nicht um die
Worte, sondern um die Art und Weise,
wie das Ganze übermittelt wird.
Diese Babysprache dient
zur sozialen Bindung. Aber mehr noch:
Ohne diese übertriebene,
emotional aufgeladene Sprache
würden wir als Kinder
die Sprache erst gar nicht erlernen,
glauben manche Linguisten.
Wir würden unser Leben lang
sprachlos bleiben.
Ja, das ist ganz wichtig,
was wir hier machen! Ganz wichtig!
Sprache ist also
viel mehr als nur Wörter.
Das merkt man v.a. dann,
wenn Wörter keine konkrete, sondern
symbolische Bedeutung bekommen.
Bei Metaphern z.B.
Metaphern sind bildhafte
Sprachausdrücke,
wo Wörter oder Begriffe
aus ihrem eigentlichen Zusammenhang
in einen anderen Sinnbereich
übertragen werden.
Beispiel für eine Metapher:
jemandem das Herz brechen.
Natürlich kann man ein Herz nicht
brechen, man könnte es zerstechen,
zerdrücken oder in einem Vakuum ...
Ja, jetzt reichts!
Anderes Beispiel:
jemandem das Wasser reichen.
Ich weiß nicht,
ob Mark der Richtige für mich ist.
Du, ich glaub, der kann
dir nicht das Wasser reichen,
Oder: den Nagel auf den Kopf treffen.
Du hast den Nagel
auf den Kopf getroffen!
Und jetzt das Unglaubliche:
Linguisten und Neurologen
fanden heraus, dass unser Gehirn
auf Metaphern, also auf übertragene
Bedeutung, anders reagiert
als auf wörtlich Gemeintes.
Man steckte Probanden in einen MRT,
also eine Art Hirnscanner,
und beobachtete,
welche Gehirnsregionen
bei bestimmten Sätzen aktiv werden.
Z.B. sie beißt in einen Apfel
oder sie beißt ins Gras.
Bei Sätzen mit übertragener
Bedeutung wurde nicht nur
der präfrontalen Kortex aktiv,
also der Teil des Gehirns,
der für komplexe Bedeutungs-
verarbeitung zuständig ist,
sondern auch der Motorkortex,
der für Bewegung von Arm und Bein
zuständig ist.
Also kann man sagen,
Metaphern bewegen uns.
Übertragen und buchstäblich.
Aber das ist noch nicht alles.
Habt ihr euch schon mal gefragt,
warum ein abweisender Mensch
kalt ist?
Und ein liebevoller Mensch warm?
Neuropsychiater erklären das damit,
dass zwischenmenschliche Interaktion
dieselben Gehirnsregionen aktiviert
wie physische Erlebnisse.
Z.B. das Empfinden
von Wärme oder Kälte.
Nach dieser Theorie sind Metaphern
nicht willkürliche oder
gesellschaftliche Konstrukte,
sondern sie haben
ihre Wurzeln im Gehirn.
So erklärt sich dann auch
die Metapher gebrochenes Herz.
Bei Liebeskummer
und auch bei sozialer Ausgrenzung
werden dieselben Gehirnsregionen
aktiviert wie bei physischem Schmerz.
Deswegen ist der Vergleich
zwischen einem gebrochenen Bein
und gebrochenem Herzen
eigentlich nur logisch.
Der Linguist
George Lakoff sagt dazu:
"Wir reden nicht in Metaphern,
wir denken in Metaphern".
Okay, wir reden also, wie wir denken.
Das leuchtet erst mal ein.
Einige Forscher gehen aber
noch einen Schritt weiter.
Die behaupten, dass die Sprache
unser Denken beeinflusst.
Wer von euch könnte jetzt
spontan nach Norden zeigen?
Also ich jetzt nicht.
Norden, warte mal ...
Nee, warte, der Pfeil ... nee.
Aborigines z.B. gebrauchen in ihrer
Sprache keine relativen Raumangaben
wie rechts und links,
sondern Himmelsrichtungen.
Infolge fällt es den Aborigines
ziemlich leicht, sich nach
Himmelsrichtungen zu orientieren,
während bei uns
manche Schwierigkeiten damit haben,
Google Maps zu folgen.
Hier, oder? ... Nee.
Wenn wir denken wie wir sprechen,
dann kann man behaupten,
dass die Deutschen
viel schadenfreudiger sind
als z.B. die Amerikaner.
Im Englischen gibt es nämlich
gar kein Wort für Schadenfreude.
Manche benutzen da einfach
das deutsche Wort.
(mit engl. Akzent) Schadenfreude.
Klar, es ist nicht so, dass man
keine Schadenfreude empfinden kann,
wenn man kein Wort dafür hat.
Aber Wissenschaftler sind sich einig,
dass Sprache unser Denken
in gewisse Bahnen lenkt.
Jetzt kommen wir
zum interessanten Teil:
Wenn Sprache unser Denken
beeinflusst, wie kann man sie nutzen,
um andere zu überzeugen
oder zu manipulieren?
Wie setzen Politiker Sprache ein,
um uns zu gewinnen?
Das erfahrt ihr in Teil 2.
Den gibt es bei Lisas Kanal.
Link dazu in der Info-Card.
Und in der Videobeschreibung.
Und gleich in der End-Card.
Schadenfreude.
- End-Card. - Klick it!
1,2,3: Schönschlau.
Du musst schon mitsagen! - Ach so.
Schönschlau!
Wenn ihr uns kitzeln wollt:
klickt hier für Deutsch,
da für Schönschlau
und hier oben für Chemie.
Ich möchte nicht,
dass ihr mich anfasst.